thanks for joining us America we're glad
you are here chris is with us in
Hartford Connecticut hi Chris how are
you I'm fine Dave how are you doing
today better than I deserve what's up
god bless you for all the work you do
sir thank you seriously okay so the
reason for my call I was divorced last
year and my ex-wife bought me for the
house
I signed a quitclaim deed over to her
and this year he decided to remarry a
very wealthy person and she moved into
his home and she just flatly told me
that I am no longer paying for the
mortgage which I mean I really am but I
don't know what to do because I was
working your plan pretty aggressively
and I was almost out and now this and I
just I don't know what my rights are I
don't know how to fight it I don't know
how to work it out there are some
variables that she introduced into the
situation that are they just they make
it even a harder situation she she did a
remodel occation on the loan putting
thirty thousand dollars on the back end
of it and it just all the equity is gone
and it's one hundred and forty thousand
dollars that I guess I'm on the on the
bill for here with hey you know I have a
condo here that I'm paying rent on and I
just don't know what to do sir I was
hoping for your guidance you got bad
advice from your divorce attorney
telling you to quit claim the deed
without requiring her to refinance and
yeah what she wasn't required to
refinance in the divorce decree correct
no he was she went on that yes she's in
Kentucky for extra time and she's in
contempt of court
yes yes my divorce attorney said it as
much but I don't know what that means I
don't know what that means you drag her
into court and let the judge smack her
around until her new husband pays this
house off Oh make our life freakin
miserable I just don't know if that's
the best decision for my children though
well
I don't know we have a window it'd be
custody yeah I don't know why I wouldn't
be don't you have custody yeah well yeah
fifty-fifty we we do it I mean you look
how do you lose custody causing the
judge asking the judge to enforce the
divorce decree oh that wasn't like
concern it was more keeping the peace
between the two households you know I
miss about all that okay you're the only
one wanting to keep the peace
translation there will never be any
peace I understand as long as your bow
tie that I mean I you do whatever you
want to do dude but I'm telling you this
what happened was all moneybags look at
this and goes listen we don't need your
credit just dump it and you'll bankrupt
your ex-husband in the process and we'll
just dump on him and you don't need
credit anyway anything that comes up
I'll cover it right and so I weren't no
way you should pay payments on this
house except for the fact that moneybags
forgot the fact that the divorce decree
said the judge told her she had to
refinance it and she didn't follow
through on that so she's in contempt
right and when you put that pressure on
her moneybags is gonna get a whole
different theory on how to handle this
situation okay that's where this is
coming from dude that's my that's my
supposition and in two and a half
minutes into the situation but that's
what I bet is going on and and you know
I don't know how to find representation
for this do you have servers is that
your divorce attorney won't handle it
well we split a divorce attorney so she
can't represent me in the snow why not
well because she represented both of us
in court we came to an agreement
together on what we were good at how I
understand it and so she won't take it
right well then ask her who she
recommends that we get to enforce her
piss-poor legal work okay
good lord thank you so much I really got
lucky yeah what a horrible situation you
get bad legal advice and you don't have
any representation you know this is just
horrible yeah you just you dude you
really I mean otherwise what's gonna
happen is you're gonna get foreclosed on
she's gonna get foreclosed on you're
upside down in the house and they're
gonna sue you guys for the deficit
she's going to be able to fight the
lawsuit and you ain't got time and she's
gonna bankrupt you that's what she's
trying to do and all because you gave up
the ownership in the house without
getting off the liability of the loan
you should have held the quitclaim deed
until the refinance papers were signed
simultaneous with the quitclaim date and
that you don't get my ownership until
you get me off the loan
in other words folks for those of you
going through a divorce that's how it
works and you know if me being nice
about the house when you're trying to
get me foreclosed and bankrupted on is
the only way to keep the peace there's
not going to be any peace hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]